okay so hello everybody um I'm here in
conversation with John vervet
John rebecky is a professor at the
University of Toronto she teaches in a
psychology department in the cognitive
science departments and I think in other
departments as well we it's very
interesting how we kind of came to this
discussion of two years ago as many of
you know I had a discussion with Joran
Peterson and in the discussion I talked
about monsters and zombies and someone
in the comments said oh it's funny
you're talking about that you should
check out John gravity because he talks
about zombies too and I found a little
video of his and I and I saw a guy he
was talking I think you were talking in
front of like you were in a house
somewhere and there's a and you were
talking about zombies in it and I really
thought wow he really understands in a
similar manner that what I was
understanding but then life goes on and
I gave another talk on zombies a few
years later and someone wrote me again
and said you know that John were making
just published a book on zombies and the
meeting crisis I thought oh that is
hilarious so I looked up the book and
then one of my patreon subscribers
started to tell me that he was having
nightmares about zombies constant
nightmares about zombies and he was
trying to solve the zombie problem in
order to kind of get through his
nightmares and he told me that in
discussion with with by reading John for
Becky's book and and in our discussions
talking about zombies he had he had
basically solved his his his nightmare
problem and so I thought huh so that's
great so he's like there's some things
that we can do together and talk about
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
and so yeah so so so so we're gonna talk
about a lot of stuff we'll see how it
goes but it seems like we'll actually
have to limit the number of our things
you want to talk about so John maybe you
can give a bit more an introduction
about yourself so we can get the
conversation going great
yeah as you said I'm assistant professor
teaching stream at the University of
Toronto I've been teaching there since
94 and you said I do work in psychology
Mike my core is cognitive psychology
alright so I do work on the nature of
cognition and then that overlaps and
it's part of I'm also in the cognitive
science program cognitive sciences
interdisciplinary we're trying to get
basically psychology linguistics
neuroscience artificial intelligence
anthropology to all talk to each other
because they all talk about the mind in
different ways that they have levels
using different methodologies different
oncology's getting them to bridge so we
can get some sort of coherent
convergence difficult but interesting
task so that I spent a lot of effort on
that and then as you mentioned I also
teach overload in the Buddhism
psychology meant to the health program
where I teach it force on Buddhism in
the clock side right try to explore why
is it that we see this growing
confluence between what's known as
third-generation cognitive science and
Buddhism why is it like people at
Francisco Varela Evan Thompson
increasingly there's this convergence
between these and so the thesis of that
course from which the zombie book was
born was the idea that we see this
increasing confluence between Buddhist
practice and cognitive science
epistemology and ontology as a way of
trying to address the emerging meaning
crisis in Western civilization so I do a
lot of work around that and and and what
happens is the work I do in my cock's
eye is actually sort of centrally
devoted towards that because Makani of
revolution and psychology was born out
of the idea that human beings don't
respond primarily to the physical
properties of the stimulus they respond
to the meaning of the stimulus and this
is so this has been sort of a basic
notion throughout all of cognizant
ecology but I but I became progressively
interested how within most of cognition
there was a spore problem and and then I
noticed that this is also a core problem
independently in linguistics in
artificial intelligence neuroscience and
it's sort of three interlocking sets of
problems when one is out of all of the
information now people often don't quite
get what this means to they they
equivocate between two different
meanings of equivocation there's a
technical sense of equivocation which is
probabilistic relations in the
environment that are available to us
that's very different from what we say
when I there was a lot of information in
a newspaper article what we mean was a
lot of meaningful content to us it's
part of the problem facing your brain is
but of all of this technical information
it has to select which information it's
going to pay attention to and how it's
going to convert that into meaning
meaningful information so there's that
there's this tremendous selection
problem attention and all the models of
attention about how do we zero in on
relevant information how do we exclude
or ignore the irrelevant information and
that's that and people don't quite
understand whether that's so tricky
because it's you see this is what you
can't do it's kind of like there's
anything you can't check all the
irrelevant information to make sure it's
irrelevant because that's
combinatorially explosive you know that
the uncountably long too long for you to
do in your life taking everything before
you could decide you couldn't get out of
your room in the morning right so the
thing is right it's kind of up and
please be careful with how you take this
and I know you you you will because
you're a careful thinker but a lot of
intelligence is about ignoring
irrelevance right now the thing is you
can't completely ignore it because
sometimes when you judge that
something's irrelevant it actually turns
out to have been very relevant to you
and when we realize that when we realize
that how we frame things in our
attention needs to be reframed that
we've formulated our problem in the
incorrect way that's insight but then
that takes me to the next stage okay so
once I've attended the to the relevant
information was that enough no because
then I have to choose how to respond I
have to solve my problems after cheat
my goals and the and I mean if your
viewers want there's technical papers
I've published on this more technical
talks but the basic idea is when you try
to plan what you're going to do there's
a combinatorial explosive number of
options that you have to consider so
once again out of all the possible
options and courses of actions you have
to somehow again zero in on the relevant
information you have to ignore the
irrelevant information you have to be
able to insightfully you know I read
like we connect we correct that and then
once you've decided to act if the oh now
I'm done I'm done with the relevance
problem no you're not because now you
hit the frame problem in artificial
intelligence which is whenever I'm
acting if I'm an actor everything
behaves everything generates effects
agents are different in that they pay
attention to for the consequences of
their own behavior
yeah which means when I'm acting I have
to try and pay attention to the effects
problem is I can't pay attention to just
the intended effects of my behavior
every year this happens people go into
an area where they know there's a gas of
flammable gas it's dark and they light a
match they light a match because the
intended effect is to produce light yeah
unintended side effect is boom the thing
is while you say oh well reddish what I
should do is in addition to paying
attention to my intended effect I should
pay attention to my unintended side
effect the problem is once again now the
unintended side effects that you'd have
to check in deafening definitely large
so once again so there's this
interlocking you have to pay attention
you have to formulate your problems and
then you have to determine the
consequences of your action in this
dynamic the interlocking relevance
realization and I've tried to argue with
my colleagues Tim will Oakland operate
Blake Richards Leo Ferraro right that
this is the core of what it means to be
intelligent and you see in psychology
that when people are talking about
intelligence they're talking about
they're talking about well these fluid
intelligence your online intelligence
that's relevance realization working
memory consciousness there's a growing
consensus that the primary function of
consciousness is sort of higher order
relevance realization attention is all
about dynamic relevance realizes this is
turning I at least would argue
that this is the core thing it's the
core and you see all these different
disciplines I could go into it also for
linguistics and neuroscience I'm just
trying to give you our audience and I
have this like this is the core of
cognition I often call it the criteria
of the cognitive sorry that was a speech
but I'm trying to compress a lot of
argument I think I think I think that
that you know when I when I encountered
your work I was encountered into this
notion of the meaning crisis and in
zombies and everything and then I'm when
I saw that you're working on relevance
realization I thought wow this is this
is definitely what I've been thinking
about you know for years now you know
that I guess I mean I don't comment it
it's funny because I don't come in at
sign typically I come and eat really
phenomenologically okay and and I think
with you sorry I said and I do want to
discuss the phenomenology with you right
right and so I think that my my kind of
not it's not my solution I think it's
that it's the traditional let's say the
traditional Christian or traditional
Orthodox solution has been to talk about
hierarchy and to have this notion of
attention and and and this focus on
nodes let's say these nodes of attention
and then there's a there's a hierarchy
of attention which which manifests
itself around and any kind of splinters
and splinters into basically just kind
of this chaotic potential that's are
there on the fringe and so that that it
seems like that seems to me like that's
how we experience the world and because
of that it makes it possible for things
to move let's say from the periphery
into the center and there's room for
that to happen and so like you said you
don't necessarily have to pay attention
to the things that are on the fringe
they kind of exist that these monstrous
you know and be you as forms but then as
they move closer towards the center all
the sudden they start to take their
identity starts to to clarify let say
and then they stay connect themselves to
the nodes that are already there that's
kind of how at least when I'm
phenomenologically that's how I see but
I don't like I don't know enough I'm
that's one of the things that has been
interesting for me in the past two years
has been through my kind of relationship
with Joran Peterson
I was very not anti-scientific but I was
very um
I tended to see a limited interest in
science because I thought that
approaching things phenomenologically
was more useful for living your life and
so but then this whole this whole
cognitive science all of a sudden came
on my horizon and I thought wow this is
I mean it's very interesting because it
it can help to help people to understand
the mechanisms of of attention and and
then ultimately moving towards this
notion of the sacred which is which I
hope is something we'll forget to talk
about let me respond to both your points
the first point I think one of the best
and current models of attention is
Watson's notion of prioritization and he
basically has you'll be pleased to know
he has a hierarchical model organization
so I think that courts are very well now
the issue I have and I don't think this
is an issue for you from what I've seen
in your videos I'm not clear about
Watson's I've never seen him in person
so I only have his print but his model
of the hierarchy tends to be very static
so I didn't follow made sense from an
older book from 1976 called sentience
and I see it as much more dynamic
simultaneously bottom-up and top-down
think about when you're reading right
you're building the words out of the
letters but you're also disambiguating
the letters in terms of the word you
know simultaneously bottom-up and
top-down so I tend to talk about what I
call a salience lansky hmm you're very
focal to me right now you sort of you
have your a peak in my salience
landscape and then there's this dynamic
topography that is constantly shifting
around in various ways and I don't just
mean visually also you know your working
memory you're tapping it and that's all
contributing to what you're finding
salience in this very sort of textured
and dynamic topography that's constantly
unfolding and shifting and I think a lot
of what it a lot of what consciousness
is doing is exactly creating a kind of
prospective of knowing within that
salient landscape nope that's the first
ball like it to you if I was gonna use
like Laval you can use like a
traditional image let's say that that I
tend to address you is that there me
there's a constant exchange between
heaven and earth you could say yes right
so there's it's like Earth is constantly
offering food and offering potential
right and then and then heaven is
constantly trying to embody ideas into
into into the earth and so it's like
this there's really this exchange of two
sides I think that's totally right and
so again the constants between this is
Jordan would be happy he would think
this was synchronicity everywhere your
viewers should know that you're torn and
our colleagues at the University of
trial right yeah that's that's what's
strange about this whole thing cuz it
happened kind of on the sidelines and
then finally I yeah first so the people
are watching I actually asked Jordan - I
said I when I saw Jordan a few weeks ago
I said Jordan you have to connect with
John for Venky because his idea seemed
so close to mind like can you write an
introductory email and then John reached
out to me and said oh I saw your videos
and everything and I was sure it was
Jordan who would reach out to him and
then it turns out no he had seen them on
his own so yeah all these synchronicity
is coming together is hilarious so
anyways I wanted to say that that that
notion by the way which has universals
the the relationship between heaven and
earth is very constant in both
Confucianism and Taoism foramina yeah
and so how that how that actually plays
into the work I do and relevance
realization is I talk about the idea of
sets of top-down and bottom-up
constraints that are regulating our
sense that are sort of shaping and
regulating this the space which in this
within which this salience landscape is
occurring so our brain is putting a lot
of top-down selective pressure to try
and be as efficient as possible but the
brain is also has this aspect that's
bottom-up yeah let's finally create as
many try to keep as many options open as
possible and the tweet so it's it's it's
very analogous and this is intended to
Darwin's biological theory of evolution
if the brain opens up variations and
then right and then it narrows them down
and it's constantly right the sensory
motor cycle is constantly be dynamically
shape so I'm constantly if you'll allow
me to metaphor I'm constantly evolving
my cognitive fitness mention my
problem-solving and my action my agency
now one of the one of the images that
that I've been kind of also my brother
at some point I hope you meet my brother
because he he's publishing a book right
now and he really talks about this
exchange be in heaven and earth in a way
that's the clearest that I've seen yet
but one of the one of the idea one of
the traditional ideas is this idea of
the left and the right like this the
left and the right hand or the left and
the right eye you see that in in the
story in when Christ talks about the
sheep and the goats you have this notion
of bringing closer and and and pushing
away and so as you bring closer you
bring towards unity and towards meaning
towards towards oneness and as you push
away you move things out towards
fragmentation and and fire or whatever
how you want how you want to image it
and so those two those two tendencies at
the same time that's left and the right
eye or hand playing together are what
kind of bringing together and separating
I always say that that like this this
idea in you know in in the creation of
the world that the the notion that the
logos comes in and he both separates and
unifies and he does it at the same time
because when you give something an
identity
you're both separating it out from
everything around it but you're also
unifying it as an identity
totally and so this is the whole thing I
mean again so there's people who talked
about right so the efficiency tends to
get your your cognitive processes to
integrate as much as possible because
that makes them more efficient they use
less resources they to each other but
you but as you do that you become more
rigid you you you lose the differences
so you like if I take off my glasses my
perceptual acuity goes down my ability
to differentiate things goes down so I
don't want to integrate to the point
where I get an amorphous blob exactly so
need to differentiate I need to have
that representational power and it looks
like and again you can see series of
intelligence you've got these competing
theories of intelligence to say no it's
all about integrating information
same thing with consciousness other
people say no no it's all about
differentiation what I argue with my
co-authors is no no what you have is
this dynamic thing that's constant and
the thing about that Jonathan is that
leads to complexification hmm what makes
me a complex Bieri think about like we
all started out as I goes right right
and then initially all we do is the
cells just reproduce
but something really interesting happens
right the cells start to differentiate
you know some become long cell some
become eye cells and and then they
literally self-organized many organs and
so you've got in parallel the cells are
differentiating but they're also
organizing into organs into systems and
that makes you a complex thing right
climate aeneas lee very highly
integrated and very highly
differentiated which means you have
emergence abilities you can do things
now you couldn't do as a zygote
complexification produces the it's part
of what drives our developmental stop
self transcendence that we're all we
have this capacity to transcend
ourselves in an ongoing manner and
what's really interesting is
complexification produces hierarchies
mm-hmm yeah it's really fast like right
now it seems like that's the that's the
big let's say the big question people in
terms of what you're saying we see it
happening in before our very eyes you've
got you've got Justin Trudeau saying
diversity is our strength and you've got
Donald Trump saying you know make
America great again and so you've got
these two extremes as if and people can
only see the positive of their extreme
they can't they don't understand it you
need both you need both unity and
diversity at the same time in order to
have something like in order for
something to be and and I always I tell
people that sometimes people wonder in
the Christian tradition why we have the
Trinity and and the Trinity is the is
the infinite representation of those two
things together the notion that you need
in reality the the the highest image of
all things is both absolute unity you
know completely one and then at the same
time completely three or completely
multiple at the same time without
without contradiction and so and so it's
it's it's really an image of how the
world the world works basically right
right powerful image yeah yeah so I I'm
maybe I would like I would like you to
talk a little bit about this notion of
the meaning crisis that you talk about
in your zombie because I really really
like the zombie but also because you you
talking about superheroes and all the
stuff that I'm interested in right now
to help people understand where this you
know where there are still at least
semblances of sacred stories in our
culture and you even mentioned that in
your
so maybe you can talk a little bit about
how you perceive the demeaning crisis
and and maybe a little bit about about
the monster and the zombie and how how
you see it as a sign let's say of that
meaning crisis sure sure so you should
know that my my co-authors Christopher
must've Pietro and Phillip we're
currently working on the second third
and fourth book
there's actually four books all right
the second book is going to be done very
shortly and the second book is all about
the genealogy of the meeting crisis
which we touched upon in the first book
so I mean it's kind of a long story
so I said the 12th century pretty much
well part of it is see I love challenge
you on that I think part of it is first
of all to get clear about the emergence
of this notion of meaning and wisdom
that comes about with sort of around the
collapse of the Bronze Age and that sort
of thing where the axial period where
you have the birth of all the world
religions you have the birth of
philosophy of the birth of science and
see before that you know you have this
sort of very continuous cosmos right
there isn't really differences in degree
between sort of the natural world the
social world and the sacred world they
they're they form a continuum where the
primary differences are differences of
power right and time is also continuous
time it is more of a circle and a loop
right and so what you get is you get
this and you get the notion of you know
concern of conserving getting back to
the origin the wisdom is to fit into
these cycles right and to find you know
the Vulcan thing to live long and
prosper that's the core of wisdom and
then what comes along as you get
cognition is fundamentally change first
of all the great collapse in
civilization that has ever hurt occurred
in the West occurred in the Bronze Age
collapse I mean more cities go out of
existence litters more babies author
language you'll even lost their own
writing so yeah everything is collapses
it and some of the writers on the extra
revolution have an analogy it's only
intended as an analogy so he said a sec
when the asteroid hit 75 million years
ago
you get the you know the dinosaurs a
wiped out and that that affords all all
these what was previously the small
mammals to speciate yes the idea is when
these Bronze Age Titanic empires all
collapsed now with all these smaller
societies that are reviewing all this
experimentation and then you get the
invention of a lot of what I call psycho
technologies this sacred a tool fits
your biology like suppose I had a bottle
or a glass right the glass fits my
physiology and enhances it but he was
trying to carry around water in my hair
and it's pathetic but this really
enhances it well psycho technologies
that they they're designed to fix your
cognition they're ways of formulating
and processing information that fit your
cognition and enhance it one of these of
course is literacy think about how much
literacy empowers you to I mean if I -
if I was the state literacy not language
literacy away from you the problems you
know it solved the people you could
interact with the amount of good from it
would just collapse like that's so what
happens is and we don't know quite where
it looks like it's in its time it looks
like it's an ancient cane in ancient
Israel it's not clear because the
distinction between proto ki brew and
Canaanite is so it's it's controversial
but the thing is you can invention of
alphabetic literacy right an alphabetic
literacy just opens up literacy to way
more people you see and and what that
does it puts the power of distributed
cognition in your hands and it also does
something else that allows you to
externalize your cognition you can look
at your own thoughts you can come back
to them again and you can share your
thoughts over time and space with other
people right and what that does is that
produces what's called second order
thinking everybody has metacognition
everybody's aware of their own can
become aware of their own mind but
second-order cognition is about if I put
that psycho technology in to my
metacognition when I'm aware of my own
mind I can use the power of literacy to
really enhance it and to I can
externalizes become much more aware of
my
i've my mistakes my errors and then much
and and then i can use that power to
self-correct and what a lot of people
argue myself included is this and other
things like numerous
there's a whole bunch of new because
currency is invented coinage right all
of these psycho technologies really
empower our ability our abilities to
self-correct right become become just
massively enhanced now I think that
carries with it a phenomenological and
existential change yeah because what
happens is what would seems to happen is
there seems to be this radical
transformation historically in people's
sense of responsibility for violence
mm-hmm
so you know in the in the pre axial
world violence is kind of part of you
know just the natural order of things
but what seems to happen right and you
see this you see this I think I think
you see this emerging in the Bible I
think you see clearly see this emerging
in the axial revolution in Greece you
see it clearly with the rise of Buddhism
in India right it's this sense of no no
our capacity for self-deception is so
great you know very self-destructive and
this are the way our mind makes meaning
and here's the connection it's deeply
responsible for how we're suffering
creating illusion hurting each other but
there's the other side but what we're
also wherever minds capacity right for
self transcendence from insight for
realization for breakthrough and I think
what happens mythologically and I hope
you understand I don't use myth to mean
things that you know false beliefs yeah
I wouldn't be talking to you yeah I
understand myth as a kind of symbolic
grammar by which we try to articulate
and express yes see these kind of
fundamental properties and/or
transformations in our cognition and
consciousness so miss aren't sort of
ancient stories about the past that are
irrelevant they're they're about
perennial patterns your pivotal moments
in the transformation of consciousness
and cognition so I think we are sort of
an agreement about the okay so I think
what emerges is a two world mythology
the to the point about the two world
mythology there's a deep grammar there
it's trying to articulate this
difference it's there's the there's the
everyday world of suffering and illusion
right and there's different ways of
doing that you can think of it as
illusion you can think of it it's fallen
you can think of it as something that we
have to transcend in the future
there's various ways of unfolding this
grammar and so I'm not gonna talk about
it specifically right now but then
there's that there's the prior world
there's the world that we can realize in
both senses of the word we can come into
awareness and we can make real so when
we can be most real and what happens is
the notion of meaning is about being
connected to the real world notion of
wisdom isn't about fit why would you
want to fit into the everyday world why
do you want to live long and prosper in
this torturous world of suffering and
delusion wisdom becomes known oh how do
i itself trance and so that I can
increase the meaning I can increase the
connectedness to this realness where we
can stop suffering and we can come to
come to flourishing and so what happens
is you get this whole axe your world
mythology and then I think what happens
is philosophers and thinkers may I won't
go through them all but I'm thinking of
Plato and Aristotle you know
particularly platonic friends like
really really important interests that
I've been I've been watching some of
this stuff or you also do the Eastern
Orthodox Christianity and just to me I
don't know very much about it I'm just
amazed about how much Neoplatonic like
language and discourse is in there
anyways and then and then Augustine
Augustine is a pivotal figure and what
happens is we get they sort of
articulate this to world's mythology
into sort of three conceptual orders now
there's a difference between the
mythology in the conceptual order but
they're tired tied together one is sort
of a numerological order this idea that
we are sort of radically connected when
we know things we're realizing them
we're getting connected to reality and
it's making us more real and then and
then this brings sort of an ohm
illogical sense that we can improve
ourselves as we make these connections
to realness as an enhanced meaning we
overcome foolishness we afford
flourishing we become more wise and then
that's linked particularly by Augustine
because obviously takes basically
Platonists and the narrative heritage
and what what's going on there is the
axial revolution and
you I hope you believe I do not want to
trespass on your Christianity and anyway
I'm deeply respectful of it so I'm not
trying to be reductive here so I'm
saying one of the things that happens in
the judeo-christian revolution is right
the idea of the open future you get the
idea of the narrative idea of history
and I see this particularly mental
mythologically represented in the God of
the Bible because unlike the pre acts of
God's he's not a God of a specific place
or location or function he's the God of
the open future he's the God of the
exodus he takes you out of the
prototypical pre axial civilization
Egypt and he takes you the new world the
new world the promised land is the real
worlds where we're going to come to
fruition flowing with milk and honey
symbolism votes right and this idea that
our that we can co-create with God we
can participate in the creation of this
future but by the moral quality of our
action by how we participate in this
unfolding narrative it was Augustine's
brilliance to bring that that Hebrew
Christian notion right into this
integration with the Neoplatonic
right and the normal logically you see
sort of Aristotle I'd you at least I see
Aristotle and latinas and and the whole
like I say Hebrew Christian tradition
being brought like integrated together
into the narrative order so this is let
me get the sense of progress and we get
the sense of purpose so even people who
are highly secularized this is my this
is the point sorry it's been a long
speech I'm trying to compress them off
even people who are secularized still
try to understand the meaning of their
life in terms of how it progress is
learning the purpose or they understand
it in terms of the normative how am i
self actualizing how am i
self-transcending or they understand it
no more logically how well connected am
i to reality so you can reliably do this
for example one of the things that
really contributes to people's sense of
meaning in life is their relationships
to other people but watch this you can
say people how many of you are in meet
like really satisfying personal to put
up their hands and I'll say how many of
you would want to know if your partner
was cheating and even if that means the
destruction of the relationship and
everybody put up
this is insights right in addition to
whatever we want to be meaningful we
want it to be real we want connecting to
what's real and so this being in touch
with reality this self actualization
this progress right all of these are
still the grammar secular or whatnot by
which people try to conceptualize right
this axial legacy of wisdom and meaning
the problem is as you said from the 12th
century on that we start we start
meeting differently we start moving from
recitation - silent meeting right we do
that there's there's there's the there's
the within theology there's trombones
awesome right and you got right and so
you get you get the priority of will oh
right
see what's in Augustine right for me
what you see is you see this deep
interpenetration and this goes back to
play it on Platonists between love and
reason they're completely interpret
defining interdependent yeah want
happening in Aquinas and then like
pushed by öktem is that no no the the
the its separated right there's the
there's the natural world is crossed by
reason and then the supernatural world
is grasped by love and now love is
separate from reason love is an act of
will it's an act of assertion and then
Baca brings in this idea that the
primary feature of God is his will right
and then the Black Plague comes along
and right and so what happens is this
notion of willful imposition
arbitrariness power starts to come back
and what happens is right all of the
orders start to collapse you have the
Copernican revolution which radically
undermines that Aristotelian framework
now experience is blinding us disconnect
the nomological collapses because the
whole Neoplatonic hierarchy is lost
right and then you get of course with
Galileo you get the emergence of the
inertial universe and so all sense of
purpose and narrative is removed so we
have the scientific worldview I have to
come I saw my students at cognitive
science one of the central tasks of
cognitive science is solving this
problem we have a scientific worldview
in which we don't belong exactly we
don't live in the same not live in a
sign
world you you it's it's a form of a lien
a alienation like to think that you live
in that world is to be very alienated
into your actual experience so what
happens is we have this whole
mythological and conceptual grammar
we're still using it yeah we're still
using it but it's not it and be careful
here don't misinterpret me I'm a
scientist I believe value of science
right but the the Scientific Revolution
the Protestant Reformation what's going
on in the 12th century did the changing
and reading the the stuff that did the
change in the conception of God where
what's primary about him is is what you
would say his news but it's his will
right and that's that's leads right to
Nietzsche's will to power line there
between you know with the dominant
feature of us and God is our will not
our irrational love or are loving
rationality but I will our assertiveness
and believe goes from believin giving
your heart to assertion to research
assertion to assertion right and so I
think what I mean by the MTG crisis is
what we see is we still have this
grammar all the way back to the actual
period of trying to understand meaning
but the two worlds mythology and the
three conceptual orders that allowed us
to express it articulated celebrated
Sherratt they have all been seriously
seriously undermined by our intellectual
and cultural and also economic history
because we also live more by ourselves
right also bad right so all of these
things have conspired I don't I'm not a
conspiracy theory yeah right continue
basically undermine our ability to right
to access the these three orders and to
partake in the axial mythology so while
you still while it went well it still
fills our cognition because we still use
literacy and numeracy and second order
thinking we still have these experiences
we don't have the means for as I say
articulating expressing celebrating and
so we're in a meaning crisis and so
people keep looking for seeing
that will feel surrogate things that
will give them a sense of purpose a
sense of self-transcendence give them a
sense of connectedness etc yeah
mean by the meaning crisis and I think
the zombie is a mythological in the
sense that we mean our technology way of
trying to articulate even celebrating it
you talked about the zombie woman's
Numbi want to celebrate it it's a weird
thing right right and what they're
trying to that zombie represents right
this loss of meaning the loss of
intelligibility the loss of
connectedness the loss of community even
the loss of shared cultural meaning the
loss of purpose the loss of all of these
things yeah well one of the things you
know in a normal like in the in the
traditional world you you would have
these cycles right yeah and so I know
that you talked about how how
Christianity is more linear and moves
towards let's say the eschaton but there
there is in Christianity there there's
both movements like there's the surgical
year and then there's that there's this
movement toward the eschaton but the
eschaton is also it's it's circular to
an extent in the sense that it's a
return to the garden but they the
expansion of the garden into the
totality let's say but what I wanted to
get to is that in a normal world you
have at the end of each cycle you would
have these carnivals yes yes and the the
carnot like the zombie would have been I
mean obviously it wasn't but something
akin to the zombie is what you would
encounter in a carnival that is this a
moment like a a moment of loss of
meaning at the end of a cycle yes so
that it's like everything has to kind of
go back to into death and then then
everything starts again you know and so
the the sense that I get is that let's
say if you have these little cycles you
know and and every year you have the
carnival and then you know then you have
these in the Bible you have like a the
week with the Sabbath at the end and
then you have the Jubilee 50-year
Jubilee you have and then like at the
end of every year you have poram so you
have these you know these cycles on
cycles and cycles and so it feels like
now like the whole cycle it's a from you
know from either with you how do you
call it the actual the actual age
yes first turn right yeah it also talks
a lot about it I'm fine using that using
that using that term like let's say from
the act the whole the whole cycle we're
reaching the carnival of that whole
cycle so it's like everything has as has
become upside down and everything is is
is the monster as entertainment is
diversion you know and so there's all
these these out so it's as if it's
filling up our whole whole society like
our whole society is a clown Society
basically and so and so it's like
there's definitely a huge shift that has
to happen like that has to happen in
order for things to to to start again I
believe so I mean I think what's
happening is we're sort of degenerating
I think that's the right word into sort
of the lowest level at which that
connectedness is available to us which
is salience yeah it's sort of the
salience is what grabs your attention
right and let's let's not pretend that's
an intrical part of meeting if the
things didn't grab your attention you're
facing that the amorphous combinatorial
explosion so it is important but it's
not sufficient right you have to you
know that salience landscape has to it
has to configure right it has to
configure how things are present to you
it has to open up affordances for you it
has to it has to set up this Clifford
Geertz his idea of a relationship
between age and gender Reena the world
has to be though you have to have this
connectedness yet the world a place for
action and you have to be connected to
yourself and other people so that you
are irrelevant after within it and we
aren't that's what we just said a while
ago we don't fit into the arena that
science presents to us well there's a
kind of there's a kind of salience which
I mean tradition would be called desire
I mean with our own passions let's say
and so that type of salience which is
the the the attaching oneself to to some
passion then that's that's exactly I
mean that's a real it's a it's real in
the sense that it's it it feels like it
gives you life let's say that it
enlivens you but then it ends up
disconnecting things from each other you
know and so that that's really that's
like the traditional I'd say I know you
said you don't know a lot about Orthodox
in orthodoxy we have this notion of the
entering into the heart like this
a stick anthropology where your desires
are on the edge and they pull you you
know but they're not bad but they're
meant to be connected together kind of
moving towards this this central place
where the illumination happens I get
that from sort of the Neoplatonism that
I'm familiar with
I mean I think you in one place you
describe me as a secular Buddhist that's
how other people I think I talk more
about my practices and I'm a devoted
practitioner right some Buddhist
practices the passion of meditation
Metta contemplation I also practice a
lot of Taoist practices Tai Chi each one
Jan Jeong Huijin I also practice
Neoplatonic practices of dialectic
contemplation Davina right I do
so it's call me a secular Buddhist is a
little right so but I wanted to point I
wanted to bring up something and I hope
you don't mind me using a term because
we used it in the book and it's
important because it's been used in
academic circumstances and it's
culturally problem and this is hairy
Frankfurt's notion of [ __ ] and I
think it's very important to talk about
that I don't mean to be vulgar but an
important term because there's a
distinction between the bullshitter and
the liar right the liar manipulates you
by depending on your commitment to the
truth right and and and the [ __ ]
artist works differently the [ __ ]
artist works by getting you to disregard
how salience should attract truth mm-hmm
so what the what the [ __ ] artist
does is just try to make things salient
to you right so there's a great episode
in the The Simpsons where the two aliens
they're running for political office
right and the one gives the speech and
he says my fellow Americans when I was
young I dreamt of being a baseball but
we must move forward not backwards
upwards not backwards twirling twirling
toward freedom and you feel this sort of
rush if you're an American right and
it's like there's nothing being said
there yeah but advertising works the
same no exactly that yeah okay so here's
a but here's the here's the existential
cognitive point I want to make and this
is not a point that Frankford me this is
so this is the point I'm making on the
basis of Frank I'm not trying to take
credit I just don't want to miss a
tribute to him right you keep we have we
have metaphors of self-deception as
lying to yourself but that generates
what philosophers called the paradox of
self-deception because how could you
possibly lie to yourself that doesn't
ring but here's the idea you can
[ __ ] yourself mm-hmm
because the ways the way attention works
maybe we talked earlier and attention
it's both bottom-up and if I make
something salient to you then it'll draw
your attention but by paying attention
to it you make it more salient and then
you get this thing and that's how it
works the advertiser shows you
here's people drinking in a bar they're
having alcohol look at all the
attractive happy people around go into a
bar it's not like that right and you
know it's you know it's not true and
they know you know it's not true but
they make that product salient - and so
when you go into the store what do you
do you buy the product right you buy the
product we deceive ourselves through
this capacity for [ __ ] and part of
work is endemic at least we argue this
and there seems to be we have some
empirical evidence for it which seems to
be part of the meaning crisis is this
increasing stance of [ __ ] and by the
way here's what I would want to argue
when people talk about being in a post
truth era with Trump post truth is just
a euphemism for [ __ ] yeah right and
we are in an ear like if you track the
the complaints the worry the concern and
these two are locked together that the
prevalence of bullshitting and the
increasing capacity for self-deception
yeah I think what happens when salience
is all that's left
yeah that's really interesting and I
think that you're right that in a way
you know the the kind of bullshitting
that we're seeing now and in the
political sphere we've been prepared for
that for the you know the last 50 years
like they just are preparing us
constantly and I think that you can you
experience it too like every time every
time you give into some passion like it
whether it's eating your second piece of
cake or whatever you know there there
really is this idea that you know if you
if you would stop and you would think of
the effect it's gonna have on you like
you know that you know but it you there
is a lying to yourself like there is a
there is a hope if you focus on the
piece of cake right and you focus on on
that then it's like all the rest just
vanishes
you just zoom into that and so you
you and then and then then you realize
it afterwards then it's like you have
this wake up you know you have the
wake-up moment after you write
compassion it's like oh okay what did I
just do you know why did I do that and
and I mean there isn't uncut I mean you
really do feel like there's this slip
into unconsciousness right you can feel
it almost happening to you you kind of
you kind of just focus in on the on the
desire and then your consciousness just
kind of slips on this but and maybe this
will line up with your Eastern Orthodox
anthropology because Plato talks right
about the tripart plate it was it was
trying to figure out I mean that's the
core he trying to understand why did
they kill Socrates and he comes up with
this idea he takes the phenomena being
her conflict as the the core thing he
wants to understand how are people
getting in like eating the second piece
of chocolate cake why does it happen
right and it gets the idea that we have
different that our cognition isn't sort
of a monolith there are different there
are different centers of functionality
and they and they have different
phenomenology and cognitive framing
associated with there's a part of us
that's very stimulus bound and it's very
urgent and it's designed a now as to
enable and enable us to work with what's
in the present moment right here right
now urgent you got if you try to
eradicate that you can't get out of bed
and then and then there's another part
of us that's that that's that's our
cultural right that we we are not just
biologically shaped we are culturally
shaped and then there's the part of us
that is capable of abstract goals right
and then Plato's point was no no the
problem is right you need to get these
into alignment you need and and this is
if you want to underplay say you wanted
to lose weight you know what you do yes
you rationally you believe it but that
is practically insufficient yeah right
you need to go and join a group you need
to get this connected to other people
business in cognition that cult he calls
it the lion the man and the lion
together can control the monster and I
think this is another important thing in
Plato right Plato not only discovered
that we want to be in car then he
discovered the meta desire in addition
to whatever we desire we desire to be
real he also discovered
the other men desire in addition to
whatever we desire we desire to have it
with peace of mind we desire to have
this internal alignment so we're not at
war with ourselves we have this heart
and his great insight in my opinion is
the idea of an agog a the ascent that
these can be linked together as I align
the parts of the psyche right the thing
about that inner conflict right when I'm
when I mean inner conflict the monster
is making things salient way above and
beyond what I believe that's [ __ ]
yes that's that that's the field of
[ __ ] yeah but if I can get more
properly aligned myself deception
decreases I start to see a little bit
more deeply into reality that satisfies
that desire and then reality starts to
disclose itself to me aids me in
aligning the psyche and these loop
together as I get more internally
aligned to get more aligned with reality
as I get more aligned with reality I get
one turn only right and this an agog a
the ascent out of the cave the famous
myth in Plato yeah to me it is I think
the great insight and what I think when
I say we're Lakme but wisdom
institutions I'll say to my class where
do you go for information the Internet
yeah where'd he go for knowledge well
science the university where do you go
for wisdom and there's a deafening
silence don't have institution and
cultures that afford an acog a we do not
have that anymore dad to also what I
mean by we lost the meaning program
that's also what has been lost in the
meaning Christ not have collections of
people with that are instituted together
to help us afford an agog a rank I mean
I think I think that maybe that's where
week that that's where we will kind of
disagree in the sense that I I think
that one of the things like one of the
things in your book you talk about this
this mean crisis and kind of the break
the break down of the Christian the
Christian narrative let's say and I and
I totally agree obviously I think that's
what's happening for sure but I the the
the other thing that I see is that the
the Christian narrative seems to have
that breakdown in itself right and so
the Christian narrative sets itself up
as as a as something that will die and
will come back like Christ died and came
back and Christ says you know this idea
like when I return will will I
find faith on in the world and so it's
notion that there that even the church
itself has to somewhat die or at least
come down like go down into death and
then and then come back and so I I to me
I I don't see the crit like I don't see
the Christian narrative as being
completely done I see it as as part of
that kind of dissent you know it's in
that obvious dissent but then there's
something I
I think minute that there side doesn't
mean that what's gonna totally come out
of it is going to be the same as what
was there before but I think that that
that there is something in the there's
something in the story of Christ which
anticipates this like anticipates this
going to the end and then and then
coming back and so and so for me I still
think that the best place in order to to
find that alignment is is the church
because still like you still actually do
physically go to the same place you do
physically stand in the same direction
you you sing together you you you recite
you all those things are there to create
that that common experience but then
there's also an anthropology and a
spirituality especially new I think
especially in the Orthodox tradition
which is a mystical transformation of
the person through through through the
Jesus Prayer and hesychasm and all that
so so I still think that that that
that's so so but I because in your book
you don't you don't spell out the
solution only one book so maybe give me
a sense of what you think like how what
could we as a solution at least like a
mix of a social and and Peart because
you talked about how your practitioner
which is which is a personal solution
that's not a social like it doesn't
bring people together no no I mean but I
also create social settings led sorryi
wisdom Sangha for many years I teach
meditation contemplation classes I agree
with that and I and I think that's a
very important point and so I want to
acknowledge that there is some
significant self-criticism when I say we
don't have wisdom institutions I'm not
exempting myself from that I want to I
want to be clear from that
secondly so there's there's a bunch of
things I want to say first is like I
showed it over you and I shouldn't ever
apologize I tend to get very
enthusiastic as you can see I love that
don't worry it's the first book in four
books right and because we part of what
I teach my students about how to be
rational and cognitive is like formulate
the problem really well it goes back to
what we talked about at the beginning if
you haven't done really good relevance
realization really good problem
formulation
you're not gonna get the insight you're
not going to get the solution this is a
very complex problem laying out the
mythology and I mean that the deep sense
Whedon the genealogy in the second book
the third book is all about the
cognitive science of meaning and
sacredness and we need to and then the
fourth book is okay what with us what
what how can cognitive science
contribute to that so there's that the
the first about what I think what I
think is and I wanted to mention this
earlier I think that third generation
cognitive science is so let's let if
you'll allow me let's distinguish two
different things
let's distinguish sort of the historical
factors and you talked about this very
nicely in the trajectory that have led
us to where we are
akhom through to Descartes etc those are
different from the perennial problems
that human beings face just because they
have self-consciousness right right
there's perennial problems of
confronting absurdity and or meaningless
despair right all cultures have that
normally what cultures have right is
they have and and I think this is the
right way to use it they have some sort
of religious Matt a meaning system that
coordinates psycho technologies so that
they have a way of existentially and
ethically responding perennial problems
now arms the problem with us is we're in
a historical situation where our
worldview we don't have world for you to
mimic it doesn't do that for us so part
of the part of the solution the
historical thing is to understand and I
think you're seeing some of it right now
I think I'm a representative right I'm
third-generation card-sized this
generation of cog side is trying to
radically under
my that Cartesian grammar of
disconnectedness we're not the mind
isn't radically disconnected from the
body my aren't radically disconnected
from each other they're not radically
disconnected from the world we talk
about embodiment and embeddedness and
connectiveness right these are becoming
and I've tried to show you a little bit
and what I'm trying to exemplify the
generation Clarke site is radically
trying to undermine that worldview in
which we don't belong right it's aching
cognitive science is taking I call it
the naturalistic imperative in carbon
sizes how do we fit back into this world
right yeah so I think cognitive science
is going to is helping now what's
interesting for me and so let's talk
about this is for me the the the the the
I don't know what to call it the
spiritual tradition the sappy ntral
tradition both those words are a little
bit inadequate put them together in
something we don't have a term for a
good ism is what a lot of the people in
third generation cog sigh are attracted
to sort of Buddhism and Daoism part of
that is purely historical part of it is
because those are traditions that aren't
part of that second in history but want
to get outside of that history because
they don't want to fall prey to it and
so I think that's a very I don't I don't
think it's fair to just ignore that
I think legitimate concern people have
so I I would hope and this is a real
hope I'm not being coy here I would hope
that the resources that people like you
have within right Christian and like I
said I'm especially a appreciative of I
want to talk to you about I just ran an
experiment on mystical experience and
how it contributes to meaning in life
like the data is like it's there like
III I would love it if you guys could
also articulate that but what I wanted
to say but and then I will return things
back to you is I say the very same thing
about Buddhism mmm-hmm that you said I
say look because a lot of people are in
the class and they come in with Buddhism
I say and here's what I'm influenced by
Stephen box for a lot as you know he's
become a post Buddhist we've not had a
very good
discussion the Buddhism that's going to
come out of this interaction with
cognitive science is not going to look
like the Buddhism right now mm-hmm right
it's they're going to they're changing
each other right the sappy ntral the
cultivation of the wisdom practices
within Buddhism right and the science
within the cognitive science they're
changing each other and what's going to
come out on the other side I don't know
what it's going to be to look like so I
I mean Buddhism has done this repeatedly
right it goes into China and it means
Taoism and becomes Chan and it travels
right into Tibet and because but becomes
Vajrayana it travels to Japan and meets
Shinto and right right and becomes Zen
you know so the idea of a single
Buddhism constant so I think I'm in
agreement with you that I think
something analogous is going to happen
so here was here's what I would say I I
mean this is a friendly friendly
challenge part of the issue for many
people is a as I've already mentioned it
and you were nodding so I think you were
giving it some acknowledgement this
desire to escape from the historical
constraints that were in and then
coupled with that is sort of a
pluralistic understanding you understand
it like I see I see people cultivating
what I would call real wisdom and
compassion within Buddhism within Taoism
within Zen and so for many people the
idea of a singular voice on this seems
very questionable to them mm-hmm and so
for me that's what I ultimately mean
when I say I'm sort of non-theist
secular that's I'm not I'm not like Sam
Harris I'm not trying to I'm not trying
to attack religion I'm trying to say
what can we draw from all of them that
can be shared by all of us right yeah I
think that I think that the for me that
the difficulty in that and I mean I've
had my kind of flirtation with that idea
let's say before I became work that I
was I kind of flirted with perennialism
and those types of ideologies I think
that I think that the difficulty that I
came to to realize
that you have to embody a narrative like
you have to live inside a story yeah
and so the difficulty of the of the
let's say of that approach of let's say
wanting to take into account Laurel ISM
within your own story sure is that you
end up you end up being on them on the
margins you end up living in the in the
margin right you you can't enter into
the story so to me there's there has to
be a way to be able to live in the story
and to embody the narrative and that
also includes that includes the actual
physical you know going into a space you
know enjoy being part of a group all
that has to be part of it that's
available story I get that yeah so and
so that that has to that has to be there
right and so the the the the fear that I
have about I mean I know I don't know
enough about your solutions I knew I
have seen kind of what Sam Ayers talks
about in terms of no no yeah even
without attacking let's say religion the
idea of of pulling different different
things from from different different
technologies let's say from different
traditions and kind of okay definitely
and I mean this in the philosophical
sense I am not advocating eclecticism
right okay all right cognitive scientist
we practice synoptic integration I mean
I mentioned at the beginning there's
very difficult practice right you know
of how do i integrate the ontology the
epistemology the methodology of
neuroscience with psychology with
artificial intelligence like that's
really I'm talking about that I'm
talking about trying to come up with a
synoptic integration we both
acknowledged I think that in the history
even in the history of Christianity I
mean like the way platanus all were
brought together by Augustine that's
that's a radical thing and many people
first rejected it when Augustine did
this talking about that I'm talking
about that kind of transformative
synoptic integration that's going to
produce something that is not currently
foreseeable I'm not trying to be an
empty utopia what I'm saying is I'm
trouble no here are the practice
you do you know you know here's how you
do the cognitive science here here's
what the cognitive science says here are
the kinds of processes of attention and
insight and reflection and self
regulation that seem to reliably
correlate predict help to afford enhance
meaning in life we are studying all of
this scientifically right now right and
so I am saying no get these two talk to
each other as much as possible so not
I'm definitely not advocating either
perennialism or eclecticism that's
talking about this kind of synoptic
integration that we have seen being
vital like like a Kairos in you know in
moments in our history these things have
come together and I gave you instances
both from Buddhism and week and you've
acknowledged there's a disease there's
these chaotic moments within the history
of Christianity to we're not careful
stopping that's what I'm talking about
yeah yeah I think I mean I I think they
definitely let's say I mean I guess I
could say this way in a way that would
be that would some people might not
understand what I'm saying but I think
that that's the idea of the return of
Christ in Christianity has to do with
this with this notion because the the
all coming together let's say it you
know in the end it has it has to happen
in this in a story like it also has to
happen to a certain extent it has to
happen in a person which is why most
most religions have these central
figures Moses you know Buddha Christ
like their hat it has to be embodied in
in in the world i i i don't think i mean
that wasn't doesn't have a person right
that was i mean they do but he's not as
he's not as prevalent
he's almost abstract i agree that was um
definitely but is yeah that's that's for
sure Taoism is different and that might
be the I said it might be the the
exception that that but we're not I
don't know how Chinese we are if there's
something there's something very
particular about far about for East Asia
like way of being that
- I mean you I mean I like this Taoism
is like swimming or making love you have
to do the practice but you would say
this yeah you have to go into church you
have to do the literature there was
sight with people you have to do the
Taoist practices I've been doing them
for 20 years it gives you like you get
an understanding you get this
respectable participatory understanding
that isn't the same as having beliefs or
assertions about the nature of reality
etcetera it's this other thing and so I
do think that that's definitely there in
Taoism in a particular way and so for me
and again I'm not trying to press you
that's but that stands and that stands
for me as this this like but here is
this my and people say well that's
impersonal no no that's not right either
it's the dow isn't personal or
impersonal it's it's it's neither one of
those if you the way that can be spoken
of is it is not the way if you try to
lock it down into either one of those
categories you are missing you're
missing that dynamic coupling that is so
central to relevance realization that we
were talking about from the very
beginning I think that was amiss largely
the religion of getting into the flow
state and and we're doing increasing
cognitive science about the flow state
and we know that the flow state is
deeply conducive to people's sense of
meaning in life and the more people get
into the flow state the better
they judge their life to be independent
of a lot of other variables and I think
I wasn't plugged into that in a very
colorful fashion hmm I think I think
maybe we can I was simply do want to
talk about sacred let's shift gears and
talk a little bit instead since you
didn't mention relevance realization and
that's something that interests me so I
I would like to hear a little bit about
your your your vision of how relevance
realization connects to the notion of
the sacred sacred space or or even even
you know sacred objects or sake the
sacred in general yeah okay so so I mean
a couple of caveats
I mean if every academic says this I
mean this is complex and but I but I I
and I'm not I'm not trying to divert you
from possible criticism but
this is very much still you know
something a work in progress this is all
I think of all of my work all of my all
of my scientific work all of my
existential practices all of my sake
actual endeavors are all pointed towards
getting this okay
you want to put it that way so right now
because I think the ability whatever
what we were talking about we were
disagreeing in some ways agreeing and
others getting back to an enacted
sacredness ultimately the solution to
the meaning crisis also I was talking
about about solving historical things
affording people an agog a affording
them self transcendence wisdom
compassion all of all of that a way of
putting that in a sentence is okay can
we today today give people this right
the sacred so how I how do I think this
connects to relevance realization I
think it connects in some very
fundamental ways first of all when I say
relevance realization where I was
talking about it
right it's not only evolving it's deeply
involving what I mean by that is
relevance realization isn't a cold
calculation of where I should pay
attention it's about where you should
pay attention and what you really care
about where you pay attention it's it's
deeply affective to you engaging of your
energies it'll touch your central sense
of agency you deeply care relevance
realization isn't only about coping it's
also it's inextricably also about caring
and bound together then Heidegger said
design is care yes yes fully agree
that's like whether definition it's
something you should know about that
historically is you know Heidegger has a
huge influence on Dreyfus Herbert
Dreyfus Dreyfus intraductal he what he
did is he is the conduit of Heidegger
into cognitive science he read for
example being in the world by Dreyfus
you'll see the term he is invoking
repeatedly to try and disk disclose what
Hydra goes on about is relevance needs
relevance relevance relevance relevance
and he was and it was drivers who
criticized sort of the older
computational models what
Peters can't do right because if they
couldn't do relevance realization mm-hmm
so there's a you're exactly right
I know yes that is a direct explicit
line into my thinking hmm so it's about
this caring but but let's pay attention
to this right I'm gonna I have to make
very quick gestural arguments and I
invite your readers to look elsewhere to
other talks and published work so I'm
not arguing from authority but I can
only give like I want the phenomenology
of this relevance realize it yeah right
it is it is much lower than the level of
our sort of propositional thoughts right
and our logical grammar think about it
you talk about this in just was it the
one on when you're doing the church and
you're doing Jacob's Ladder yeah yeah
and you talk about this and you even you
indicate you indicate how there's sort
of a pre conceptual element to this
because you talk about this like you
know that yes my finger pointing yes
right so think about the monster of
reference the monster you've referenced
right any attempt to categorize things
presupposes demonstrative reference yeah
well I'm gonna say you know here I'm
going to group these things together and
see if they're all cats you know what I
have to do first like to go this this
this and that salience tagging that's
that's this initial relevance
realization that it's pre categorical
right allows you to create your
categories right whenever we're making a
similarity judgment we're not doing
logical similarity because everything
any two things share an indefinite
number of property we're judging the
relevant similarities so whenever we
categorize whenever we form concepts
were already relying on relevance
realization look if I have a concept of
glass out of all of its properties I
still I select a subset and not and
they're not just some arbitrary feature
list it's how they get felt together how
they know oh right
so out of all of this I select some
features as relevant how the relevant to
each other how they're relevant to me
representation categorization
conceptualization depend on relevance
realization all your normative judgments
depend on having meaningfully structured
experience I can't judge if something's
true good
beautiful if it isn't meaningful to me
right so all of this what I'm trying to
point to is and so I mean this
overlapping but deeper than cement and
transpersonal psychology relevance
realization is pre egoic you emerge out
of it but at the same time the same time
right the world as the combinatorial
explosives it is disclosed to you as an
arena the world and right is right so
there's also all that post 2 goack
combinatorial explosive death to a
reality but it's also being disclosed
it's being realized in relevance it's
being put into a form that can couple to
your emerging agency so relevance
realization I try to use this term its
transductive it's not what the romantics
said it's not some inner arbitrary thing
that we paint on the we express onto the
empty canvas of the world either is
locked right it's not something that the
world just imposes on our black slate of
our mind it's like and this is what
relevance realization says it's a way in
which the world and the mind are coupled
together are mutually self-disclosing
mutual self-disclosure is love yeah it's
a sound it's like a sexual relationship
yes yes exactly so and the idea is
because it has these pre and post egoic
elements to it it is mysterious in
Marcelle sense of the word we can't
ultimately frame it I can't I can't make
my relevance realization I can't
completely externalize it I'm always
framing and so whenever I try to frame
my framing oh crap I can't do it and
whenever I'm framing the world I
realized oh there's a moral compass
oh yeah exactly mystery to mystery or as
you know I I think of the verse in the
Psalms I often use the deep calls to
deep right in the song right and I think
of that as the so what relevance
realization does is it it it it couples
these mysteries so they're resonating
together in a way that Co creates our
cognitive agency and
for world to us yeah here's the thing
remember we talked about at the
beginning relevance realization is
inherently self-correcting mm-hmm
insight and think about how insight is
that flash and how many how meaningful
insights are to us yeah so one of the
things that relevance realization is
constituted to find an interest in
deeply care about is relevance
realization yeah exactly
one of the things we do is and I mean
this both in the sense of enhancing and
celebrating is we play with capacity for
a relevance realization think of a boat
music yeah it's think about how much we
associate music with sacredness because
we're playing with this process these
coupling of these mysteries the
cooperation of our agency and the world
and the way in which music is kind of
like you know moments of insight that
are being but it's like an ebb and flow
like you must from from inside towards
question towards inside towards question
it's that evolving involving and I think
so when we when we when we come up with
cultural forms mythos write symbols
stories in order to make significant to
us this significance making when we make
meaning making meaningful to us when we
celebrate incident cultivated that's
what I mean by sacred okay yeah yeah I
understand yeah I totally understand I
totally said I always tell tell people
that did like the the structure the
structure of the church let's say that
this concentric structure of the church
with Eucharist in the center and you
know and this is kind of moving towards
invisible mystery that's hidden in the
in the in the the host and everything
that what that's about is is it's about
getting you to participate in how the
world works like it is it's it's it's
not about that you know it's it's about
it's like you said it's it's about
relevant realization like it's about
it's the sacred is about knowing what's
sacred like it or participating in
what's sacred it's it it's this it's the
things which which which moves into it
itself and so so it's not when people
kind of ask you like what does it refer
to ultimately it's like with it's it's
in a way it is referring outwards
towards a certain sign
in symbols but in the end it's actually
moving into itself it's trying to move
you into that very process of moving
into something and that's what I mean I
think the coupling and that's where I
like to use the term religio as one of
the one of the contending atomo atomo
logical basis of our work religion
because it means this binding this
coupling this have all being together
the thing that I become really
interested in and I'm looking for
through the history of the actual
revolution neoplatonism Gnosticism I'm
very interested in this this note
because gnosis is this sense of
participatory knowing not just like not
just a certain propositions not just
having skills that I can operate on the
world but this sense of like no no I
know it they cut bite because I'm
becoming one with it I'm internalizing
it I'm not knowing it just with the
machinery of my mind I'm knowing it with
the machinery of myself I am being
transformed in that transformation is
disclosing is informing informing me you
know the structure of the world and I'm
really trying to get clear about the
cognitive science and the phenomenology
of this participatory knowing because I
think our if you'll I hope some
postmodern self-referential here but I
think our understanding of understanding
is impoverished precisely because we
have reduced understanding to mostly
propositional assertion right exactly a
little bit about we're now acknowledging
procedural knowledge that knowing how to
catch a baseball is very different from
knowing that a baseball is round yeah
baseball is it right but people are
starting to and I this is what I'm
really pushing a lot of work on this
perspective of knowing knowing what it's
like to be here now this this here
nowness this is a kind of knowing that
isn't the same as having beliefs for the
same as having skills Ellie called us
about this in her book on transformative
experience but below that perspective of
knowing right is this participatory
knowing right yet you know when you talk
about gnosis I always kind of because no
Gnostics are very popular right now you
know and they're kind of all around it
and it's interesting because say dear
Aeneas when he wrote his book you know
against the Gnostics it was actually
called something like the so called
Gnostics yeah
said is that when you propose when your
proposition is that lets say
phenomenological world or matter the
manifest world is corrupt in itself
you're actually missing out on true
knowledge which is this union of heaven
and earth and so he posits the
incarnation as true gnosis because it is
really this joining of all things
together like that and so it is this it
is this joining of heaven and earth in
the figure of Christ that's that's was
is true is true gnosis for Saint
Irenaeus and and it has to do with what
you're saying is that in order for true
not true knowledge is really this this
this yeah this this idea of the the we
would say the Newson inc in two so this
pre ego ego capacity to intuit the world
you know and then it comes into to
contact with the created world and then
there's this there's this unity yes this
possibility of a the transfigured world
in a world that is that is full of but
it's also but it's also not static it's
dynamic but it's it's constantly full of
life that's what I mean and I need that
fundamental I mean this is I mean this
is from social psychology you know how
you give to people to fall in love with
each other have accelerating mutual
disclosure so the more I might disclose
more about me and that makes you
disclose more about you right we will
fall in love whether it's atonic or
romantic that's how you but the thing is
that right then the knowing by loving
right which is also a theme all the ways
right
this is the participatory knowing that
we're talking about this knowing by
loving and you know and and the problem
you see you and I have had a long
discourse so we can now make those
propositions and they don't sound like
Hallmark cards or they don't stab right
but but that's a problem right no
problem
yes yeah we had I had that we had Jordan
and I had the discussion with
evolutionary psychologist brent
weinstein yeah it's on my channel if you
want to check it out and it's
interesting because we had to discuss
and we talked about relevant realization
in other terms but this notion of of how
you know that we have these deep these
deep let's say imagistic structures that
basically shape the way we then look at
facts you
like you can't avoid it and it's
interesting to watch the comments on
those on that video because the the
people coming in from the New Atheists
side they basically say you're all
gobbledygook like what you're saying is
just a bunch of you know you're just
saying stuff religious nonsense that
doesn't mean anything and of the science
of cognition right there that's just I'm
so sorry like I'm not usually this bull
that's just false it's just a false
claim I mean there is I mean there is
very good
cognitive science behind what I'm
talking about you know you don't think
cognitive science is central to the
scientific enterprise right now you're
not paying attention to what's happening
the the real possibility of autonomous
AI is impact this culture and our self
understanding in a way that is going to
make the Industrial Revolution look like
a cakewalk you're not paying attention
to cognitive science and you're off
running your idea of reducing
rationality to syllogistic reasoning
right then you're just not preparing
people or yourself for what's coming I
think that is just a deep mistake and
it's a false claim sure I don't mean to
be so straight but I'm very strong on
this that's good I'm happy no IIIi told
me I really I don't know I think that I
think I think we've been going for like
almost an hour and a half I think we
could keep going forever but with that
last that last glorious statement of
yours it might be a good place to to end
our first conversation sure I I
definitely hope that we can have more
because I I my my kind of growing
knowledge understanding of cognitive
psychology and cognitive science is is
it's kind of pushing me directions that
I ain't thought and so I'm going to keep
to keep to keep pushing it Jordan told
me to read that book the master and his
emissary I'll probably be reading that
and starting to to try to address these
questions that I haven't addressed in
those terms yet so so I'll probably look
at I mean hopefully as these books keep
coming out I'll be looking for when is
the next one coming out the next one the
genealogy of the we call it unsheltered
because we revoking the loss of the
sacred canopy that's in the member book
and I know and the whole sense of Dom
aside the loss of a sense of being at
home in the world
so we're hoping to have the draft done
by sort of June end of June and then
there'll be the two or three month
process of the publication so probably
by the fall of this year okay great I
mean I go on sabbatical in July so I'll
be able to devote more time I would vary
my book I was excited about this and it
more than met my expectations I would
love it if we could talk again I think I
mean we have disagreements but they seem
to be I mean we seem to be able to
incorporate them into furthering the
dialogue and discourse and it seems to
be mutually informing in a way that I
think we both are benefiting from like I
said you've provided me with a lot of
insights I now teaching the Buddhism and
cognitive science course in the summer
and I'm going to have my students look
at some of your work oh that's great I
appreciate that I would say if you want
to look into some a few things like I I
really tell people to look into st.
Maximus the Confessor yeah he's really
yeah he's really a key and I think he's
a key right now to helping people make
sense of what how what how religion
could fit into into the world right now
and also how it relates to through
cognition and how it relates to to the
notion of gathering phenomena into
coherent entities like he's really to me
he's a he's a he's a key and they're
stuck there was quite a few introductory
texts to his work that are that are
easily watching you talk I ordered and I
don't know each turn so I got that
because I do want to understand it
better one last but what is the
connection between people like Maximus
impe see I know Dionysius very well yes
because you could see st. Maximus as
taking Dionysius the Dionysian corpus
and trying to let's say smooth it out a
little bit yeah make it more
incarnational because Dionysius really
really he stresses the hierarchy so much
and and and so it's like st. Maximus
takes
Denise's ideas of hierarchy but then
really tries to bring them into this
notion this incarnational notion and the
idea of of the gathering in and so he a
lot of people say that he makes
Dionysius more Christian let's say that
what one of the ways that people tend to
to see say Maximus because there were
some difficulties with Dionysius you
know in some what some of the terms he
uses and he's trying to kind of help it
help make it more but he say Maximus is
really in the line of st. Gregory Mesa
as well and other other other other
fathers that were more into these
questions obviously the ones that I'm
I'm interested as well but there's also
st. Gregory Palamas who's really harder
to read because he's later and so he's
using a lot of technical terms but but
slowly but but for sure Maximus if you
read a good introduction of VMI's he's
accessible for sure and then I'll
proceed from there alright and yeah so
so I think that'll be and as I as I keep
watching your lectures I'm probably
gonna watch your Buddhism lectures as
well and so it'll give us fuel to for a
future discussion alright so everybody I
would say you can find the book zombies
in Western culture they John wrote it's
free online if you you can also order a
printed version if you want but you can
read it as a PDF online so that's that's
great and I look forward to another
discussion with John so all right don't
worry everybody if you enjoyed this
content and our exploration of symbolism
get involved I love to read your
insights and questions in the comment
section you can also share this video on
social media to your friends and as you
can please consider supporting us
financially through patreon or PayPal
you'll find those links in the
description below
[Music]